I feel the need the need for speed I
don't know why I quoted that like
seriously I mean I know Carol Danvers is
a pilot left I'm according this later
than I usually do I'm a little punchy so
Captain Marvel I have now seen it I have
been avoiding reviews of it actually as
has become my habit these days I really
kind of even from the reviewers that I
like in whose opinions I want to know if
I know I'm gonna see something I usually
hold off seeing their reviews until
after I a see and record my own review
cuz I've just reached a point where not
only do I not want I sang the idea that
I don't want my view tainted isn't
really right but I don't want my
thoughts to be in response to somebody
else's thoughts you know but anyway so
boy where do we start with this one well
um it's good it's very good I'm not
gonna call it excellent but it does work
very well
overall I'm not gonna like tell you like
specifically or we're in Marvel doesn't
rank in terms of general it's not top
tier for me because top tier Marvel is
stuff that connects with me on a more
personal or emotional level so that
would be stuff like Civil War infinity
war Black Panther spider-man Home Coming
guardians of the galaxy to those had
something in them that hit me like a
little a little closer whereas this is
the upper level of that was a good time
so that would slot it in around you know
the first guardians may be thor ragnarok
things like that so i did enjoy it quite
a bit and more to the point I don't
really have anything to complain
it just didn't have that little extra
hook that really got you know got me all
like oh yeah top stuff but at the same
time as much as I complained about how
late it is when I'm recording this I had
a long drive home from where was that I
saw it I'm not gonna explain why it's
not worth how long it would take me to
explain why that happened but I'm
actually kind of glad cuz think you on
it a bit more on the drive I made me
appreciate it a little bit better it
still didn't quite have that like
personal hook and as I mentioned but
yeah I think this is a pretty well put
together thing so story wise it is it's
interesting because it is an origin
movie but it's not structured like an
origin movie because Carol Danvers is
already a super-powered space traveling
soldier when the movie starts but she's
not Captain Marvel yet and we have some
gaps to fill in in terms of how she got
where she is at the point we see her so
it is telling an origin but it it
doesn't fall into the origin story
structure that Marvel basically said
they were done using after dr. strange
and then I I think having it be more of
a story of self-discovery as opposed to
a strict a to be to see linear origins
story helps helps it from keeping as
repetitive or redundant as it might have
otherwise with a more typical structure
and also some of the ways that she sort
of remembers more about her past and the
way that's conveyed to the audience at
times actually was quite clever both in
terms of visual composition and also the
internal mechanisms of the film that it
that are allowing this you know
information to be relayed in the way
that it is I actually I quite enjoyed
that so we we get to it's it's set in
the 90s primarily on earth so we get a
ton of 90 stuff including slow internet
and dial-up jokes and a whole bunch of
90s era
music which I actually enjoyed a lot
more than I would have thought like I
knew that stuff was gonna be in there
maybe it's just cuz I'm like I'm at that
age or I'm gonna be a sucker for 90s
style juh you know I I kinda can't help
it
it was weird even songs that I don't
really like I still find myself smiling
when like the needle drop hit and I'm
like what I don't even like I wouldn't
listen to this song in my own time why
am i smiling something's working so that
I quite enjoyed um brie Larson I
actually really liked in this part I
think she did a really good balance and
the like this is the the extent to which
I'll talk about criticisms that I've
heard this was not on the movie this was
of the trailer I remember people saying
that you know she she looks like she has
no personality she never smiles that
like well first of all she does smile in
the movie she actually has an
interesting sense of humor and and what
I like about her performance in what I
kind of expected was gonna be the case
and it turned out to be exactly what we
got which is that she is very much
trying to be cool calm and collected and
a soldier like that is her training and
that's her goal she has been taught like
this is the ideal you put your emotions
away so she's trying to clamp that stuff
down but this sort of playful snarkiness
and which is a chemistry she has with
most of the other characters keeps
bleeding through a little bit um in a
way that works for me in a way that
reads like she she can't quite repress
everything that she you know feels about
stuff but not in uh-uh your control my
emotions kind of wait just in a no you
know I know I'm on the job but I'm gonna
I'm gonna I'm gonna make you smile first
and I like that I like that vibe she'll
show really good performance chemistry
with pretty much everyone she had scenes
was she had good performance chemistry
with Jude Law or Leone I see a great
performance chemistry with with Samuel
Jackson with some of the other
characters usual
later like Marie Rambo they she she
bounces off all of them really really
well I mentioned Sam Jackson he's he
might be the highlight of the movie for
me what I really liked about him was not
only do we get him as Nick Fury but and
we get him looking younger but the thing
is for so like for as good as the d
aging technology has become especially
in the Marvel movies and it's gotten
really good there's something that he is
able to bring to this which is more than
just looking younger because sometimes
you you end up with a performance that's
like alright you look younger but I'm
still getting you know the vibe of the
age that you actually are
Sam Jackson was able to tap into like
how he was how he performed and the kind
of vibe and movies that he was doing in
the mid-90s he was able to give her
performance that not only did he look
like he did in the nineties he's he's
got the energy he's got the more
youthful energy that he that he had in
those kinds of movies it was a really
neat thing to see and he's obviously
having a blast doing this so that went
really well the other one who was the
highlight and I I knew he was in the
movie but like I not somebody I ever
really look for ben mendelsohn ben
mendelsohn plays sort of the head scroll
character the scrolls that people don't
know are a read this isn't really a
spoiler they're introduced early on I'll
tell you what I'm getting to sports
they're a race of shapeshifters and they
are at war with the Kree which is the
group that that Carroll is linked up
with at the beginning of the movie and
so the the head of the scrolls is played
by Ben Mendelsohn using I think his
natural accent which I don't think I've
ever heard from him before and honestly
that natural accent was a big part of
what made this work for me because he's
got this sort of more rough-and-tumble
feel to him so he's like a he's like a
military commander and he can be
ruthless and all that stuff but at the
same time
you listen to him talking just the vibe
off him you just feel like yeah this guy
can fight it in a war but he to really
just rather go to the pub and have a
beer and I kind of love that it's just
yeah he had a very laid-back vibe
despite being fairly intimidating at
times and I like that that balanced that
contrast and especially looking the way
that the scrawls look it was it was neat
I enjoyed that um we get Phil Coulson
back in the movies again for the first
time since the first Avengers also a.d
age they sort of brought his hairline
forward he actually looks a lot like a
young Dennis Quaid with his hairline the
way they did it that threw me off a
little bit until he started talking I
was like and then I heard his voice am i
okay well you don't sound like that way
so that's fine but he was good the one
who plays Murray Rambo the young girl
who plays Monica Rambeau also very good
I like the cat I like goose in the
comics the cats named chewy but in the
movie it's named goose annette bening
does pretty good she she is in a role
that's fairly briefly seen but her
natural presence and the sort of
gravitas that she has as a performer
helps sell the character for what needs
to go on with her um if I'm gonna have
one criticism of the film it's gonna be
that the climax probably goes on a
little too long what I mean by that is
Carol doesn't have full control of all
her super-powered capabilities when the
film starts so as she sort of gains full
access to everything she's capable of
doing after the point at which she
basically goes super saiyan the movie
goes on for a little bit too long
because once once she does that and the
film kind of establishes the full extent
of what she can do the enemies that are
on hand aren't gonna win against her you
know it's it's it's a it's a bit of a
superman thing where well nobody's gonna
be able to beat her and that's not an
autumn
attic knock on it because you can have a
catharsis in her achieving that height
and I do think that is there
I just think between the point at which
it's pretty clear that you know the
upper limit of what she can do is
totally gonna trounce the threat that's
it immediately in front of her and how
long it takes for that to actually play
out is just a little bit too long
because the the villains up to that
point they weren't on threatening prior
to that but they had been kind of been
scaled to what she could do for all the
movie prior and then you know what once
she can do everything she's gonna be
able to do she just she just kind of
mops the floor with people and it is fun
to watch but like I said it just kind of
stretches that out a little bit too long
that's honestly the only thing that I
would have to complain about
this is a really solid movie now a lack
of complaints is not the same as a
glowing review as I said it didn't quite
have that hook for me that that was able
to get me emotionally or on a more
personal level that my favorite Marvel
movies have been able to do I am gonna
talk about one other thing and this is a
little bit more spoilery because I am
gonna have to talk about a few specific
things including some stuff that happens
later on so I'm gonna get into that now
if you haven't seen the movie yet maybe
don't watch what's left here we go
so what I like about this is it does I
feel and boy I'm afraid of what this is
gonna set off in the comments was I say
this but here we go I feel that there is
a sense of feminine and feminine
empowerment but it is an undercurrent I
do not feel that it is driving the story
but I do feel it's a pretty consistent
presence and I think where that hammered
home for me and this is sort of where
the climax as much as I said it did go
on a little bit too long it punctuated
precisely right because she has her face
off against and again this was spoilers
I faced off against Jude Law who had
been her ally and kind of her mentor and
she faces off against him and he gets
all right all set up for the yoga the
the hand-to-hand fight you know
redoing of the fight that the two of
them had way back to the start you know
in training and she just isn't gonna
play by his rules she just blasts him
and she goes up and she says to him I
don't have to prove anything to you this
this person who is very much at this
point demonstrable not her equal may
have been at one point when she was
nerfed he's not now still demanding that
she proved herself to him and she just
says no I don't owe you jack
I liked that in general I feel like that
kind of vibe as I said runs throughout
it not just from from Carroll you get it
from from the Rambo's as well from both
of them Maria and Monica and again I I
feel like that that sense of a female
power is very present but not
overpowering like I said I probably
wouldn't have fully appreciated it if I
hadn't had a longer drive to get home
now that said I have no doubt that there
are probably people who went to this
movie you know prepared to look at it
with a fine-tooth comb
seeking out every bit of possibly
feminist messaging that's in there and
it is in there but it's not the the
story that stair has not been
manipulated to accommodate this there's
a story that they're telling that is a
perfectly serviceable story and they
have found a way to weave these themes
and these moments and this general vibe
into it if I were to compare it with the
other big female superhero movie to
compare it to which is Wonder Woman I
think it's actually probably a better
movie than Wonder Woman overall I don't
like it as much though because it
doesn't have anything that hits the
height of of the no man's land sequence
or to make comparison to a more recent
movie from this year it is definitely a
bad
film better put together fewer fewer
flaws than elite a battle angel but I
still like to lead a battle angel better
because I connected with that character
and just more like on a more personal
level than I did with Carol but I still
really like Carol I liked her a lot
I found her enjoyable I liked her
snarkiness it I thought that she was
really well balanced so this is a better
movie but there there are just other
ones that you know may not be as good
but just had that hook for me a little
bit more I keep coming back to that and
it's it's it's hard to know how else to
put it this is a good movie well made
well thought out good theming great
performance is really only tiny nitpicks
but it just didn't it just didn't quite
get me as much as I would have liked but
I'm not gonna say that that's a Fault in
the movie sometimes that just happens I
don't connect to absolutely every movie
that comes out it's still really good
and I think folks should see it so
that's Captain Marvel you seen it what
do you think about it whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it bunch of
stuff down there too because there's a
link to the patreon there's my p.o box
there's merch I've got new merch stuff
that's down there also I've got my
Amazon wishlist link because it's my
birthday this month and this is the one
time of year I'll be shameless and just
flat out ask send me stuff I've actually
got some really nice gifts sent already
either to the PIO box or through the
wishlist which has been kind of
flattering because I plug it and I don't
really expect anything to come of that
and you folks always surprise me in the
best ways so that'll wrap it up all
those links are down below check them
out if you want but if you don't want to
that is okay too because at the end of
the day you're the council and I'm just
running the meetings so until next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]